[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
one two is the mic working oh [__] my
mic is on the day
[Music]
only one technical difficulty apparently
I set the wrong time oh well we're here
at the right dinosaur [__] it [__] them
who cares what the announcement says we
are here at the exact same time every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the mind is touch
Facebook page also our Facebook page
holy moly
we're on YouTube YouTube channels now
our YouTube channel the Tony Michaels
podcast do not forget to hit the
Subscribe button right now
also we're on the up wire up wire.com go
follow that Creator Network broadcasting
live from the up wire YouTube channel
holy [__]
Marjorie Taylor green
thinks that there is a school in
Illinois that got five billion dollars
uh what a dumb [__]
we're gonna go through that today also
there is a very important video
that the Mussolini mango Jesus made
about education believe it or not this
is all a coordinated effort now Marjorie
Taylor green really dropped the ball
really dropped the ball
on this education narrative
in a Committee hearing yesterday and
really this is the reason why she should
have stayed officially useless what I
mean by that is she shouldn't have
really tried to get back on committees
she's not good at this at all
not good at all she [__] sucks at
this
horrible
and quite questioning Witnesses
she's not even good at lying really
honestly I mean this [__] five
billion dollars it goes to an elementary
school for wokeness or diversity or
whatever as if [__] diversity and
Equity is a bad thing how in the [__]
did these people lose their way so much
that the words equity and diversity is
their [__] enemy think about this for
a second Equity equality those two words
are their enemy what does that say about
them those America first [__] Nazis
and I'm going to show you this [__]
tape from Grandpa Poopypants the Cheeto
desk Q anoner on his plan on how he's
gonna destroy your children's education
and bring in the Hitler Youth I'm not
kidding you
I'm not kidding you this this is Nazi
type [__]
this is indoctrination grooming type
[__]
we're gonna walk through it step by step
of exactly what he's doing and why he's
doing it and what he's saying and why
he's saying it listen I understand that
there's a lot of [__] commentary out
there about his legal woes but I'm
telling you this [__] is gonna
be their nominee regardless if he's
indicted or not which he will be but he
is going to be their nominee we cannot
look through the lens of legal only
we cannot look through the lens
of only the court system is going to
take care of this [__] they are
not going to take care of him from now
until the 2024 election that is up to us
the people
the pro-democracy coalition
out here to [__] destroy him
and we must do it with our voice
and in 2024 our voice will deliver
people to the polls to make sure to
crush him with our ballots he will be
their nominee and there's only proof
this morning
there's only proof this morning he
posted a video on fraud social
of what I've been talking about the last
several weeks of why Ron DeSantis is not
going to challenge him
now this has to do with Nikki Haley but
he's also throwing shots across the bow
to any person who will challenge him
because his goal
is to go into the primaries
unchallenged
so that he can walk to the first ballot
with no no [__] trouble at all at the
Republican National Convention next
summer
not this summer next summer
that way he can tell a federal judge I
can't go to criminal trial I'm the
Presidential nominee and they will grant
him that wish folks
that is the plan and it is going to work
it will work
we are the jury that stands in his way
we are the jury that will crush Maga and
tell them no you do not get to take our
democracy away from us
you are guilty of sedition you are
guilty of conspiring to destroy our
constitution we are the jury
and we must start now
in indicting and convicting not just
Trump but Maga all together
because I don't know if you're paying
attention to the house which if you've
been listening to the show here you have
been
foreign
but we have
Ultra manga boneheads
at the helm of our country and our
democracy
and there's not a goddamn thing we can
do about it besides hold them
accountable in the next election that's
how elections work in this country
you don't just get to make [__] up and
redo an election because you didn't like
the results
that's not a thing it's not a [__]
thing we don't get to do that
no matter what Kerry Lake says no matter
what Donald Trump says we just cannot
throw out the Constitution because we
don't like our results that we made for
our government because folks that is the
that is it the Bare Essentials at the
foundation of our two-party system in
this country it is a democratic
constitutional republic
a democracy where the people are the
government
and they elect people to go vote for
them in that government
that is fundamentally how it works
and until we get people to understand
that their decisions
based on affiliation because your daddy
was a Republican and your uncle's a
Republican and your grandpa was a
republic well you're daddy your uncle
and your Grandpa are dumb [__]
I tell you that they were some stupid
bastards and still are if they're still
alive stupid bastards
and your your continuing the stupidity
by supporting the America First Nazi
party that the Republican party has
turned into now they're destroying
themselves folks this is not sustainable
they can't sustain this level of
stupidity they can't and they will be
blamed for defaulting on the debt they
will be blamed for shutting down the
government
I'm gonna make [__] sure of it if if
it's only me that does it I'm gonna make
sure of it
I am not and will not stand back
and let them control the narrative in
this country
and you are my ally in that fight
you are the amplification
of our voice
it is you that make a difference it is
you
that will drive the national narrative
that have the power of messaging
you don't need to play into defeatism
and that liberalism is weak that's all
[__]
I saw a comment today and maybe I'll
pull it up
I posted the video
and we talked about it yesterday where
Matt gatz got his ass handed to him when
he when he decided it was a good idea
to put an amendment
for members of the Judiciary Committee
to say the Pledge of Allegiance
and he absolutely got crushed in the
moment because a Democrat played the
political theater that Matt gatz wanted
to play and did it much better oh it was
oh my it's [__] beautiful
icing on the little fascist cake
that is Matt Getz and his venmo account
now someone said oh well this is just oh
it's so discouraging to see both sides
playing political get the [__] out of
here with the both side [__]
listen to me when I tell you this
and they'll tell you oh they'll tell you
over at another Network or another
[__] place some other commentator you
know I'm talking about I don't have to
say the words okay I'll say it tyt and
David Pacman and the likes of them in
their defeatism
they'll tell you oh you can't oh you
can't oh we can't get down in the dirt
we can't play these dirty political
games we can't play this political we
can't politicize the bull [__] [__]
you can't
bullsh [__] [__] you shouldn't
listen your democracy at stake I'm gonna
show you a [__] video today where
their Presidential nominee their former
president who tried to overturn the
Constitution of the United States he
said he wants to subvert the
Constitution so he could be named
dictator
is going to talk about how and what is
his plan to indoctrinate children in
this country and he's signaling to his
[__] base hey we're going to
indoctrinate children
we're going to groom children and we're
going to use it we're going to use the
big hammer of autocracy
to do it
we will use oppression if we have to
that is what he's saying in the
[__] clip
it's Nazi Germany Hitler type [__]
they're leaning into it
because he knows
that no one will stand in his way
but by God we will the people will
the majority of Americans in this
country will not stand
by why their democracy is stripped away
from them
ripped from their hands because what
because you you don't think there's any
chance for democracy you're defeated
that Democrat oh well Democrats are just
playing the dirty games you goddamn
right we are
it's time to politicize every measure
I've been saying that for two [__]
years
and we we did it in 2022. they all said
Jesus Christ in the run-up you remember
I if you were here on this show thank
you for being here and a loyal listener
and I'm glad if you weren't here you're
here now and you're hearing my voice
because the months leading up to the
2022 midterm the media tyt David packman
were believing the [__] polls they
were believing every [__] single bit
of it and I said [__] the polls [__]
that they're Antiquated they're [__]
they don't know what they're talking
about and it's all stuffed anyways [__]
them
don't listen to it don't pay attention
to it do what you need to do to save
your democracy and save your way of life
and know the truth
[__] their lies
[__] the Republican stuffing the goddamn
polls so that the media would spread
their lies so the fetus like tyt and
David packman would [__] spread their
lies on their [__] platforms not here
God damn it not here we are going to
mock their lives we're going to expose
their lives and I'll tell you why
they're [__] lines and I'll tell you
what to do about it
that's what we do here
we will not
we will not hear
act like this statement from Trump this
morning is not a threat to our [__]
democracy
we will not we will not just oh well
this is kind of crazy stuff oh my gosh
he's saying crazy things let me give you
some statistics of why of why what he
says is not true it's not you don't need
a book of statistics
you do not need even a fully functioning
brain to understand what he is saying
is designed to take away our democracy
and take away our voice and our freedom
he's really scared that Ron DeSantis
is stripping away books and libraries in
Florida
oh he's terrified he's terrified that
Ron DeSantis is doing a much better job
at appearing to be Hitler than him
that's the first thing they do folks
not only do they take away the the
content to read to know the truth they
take away your ability they're not going
to teach children to read
they don't want to teach children to
read
that's not their goal
their goal is not to raise very smart
learned people
who can learn who will learn
adults who use deductive reasoning
rational thought and logic they don't
want that
and he says it in the [__] clip
he says it out loud
and the problem that we have in this
country
isn't that he can say this [__] on
social media that's not the problem get
over yourself when you're talking about
oh they need to ban him from social
media someone needs to ban him for but
shut the [__] up
that is not the problem
the problem is in this country that we
the people are not loud enough we are
not pissed off enough we are not
outraged enough
to get the truth in front of Lies
this Q Anon [__] is a hell of a drug
folks it's a hell of a [__] drug it
allows them to believe anything they
want to believe and back it up with no
facts and no truth whatsoever
it's a hell of fascism is a hell of a
[__] drug
authoritarianism is an easy way to force
people to be what you want them to be
it's one of the easiest
foreign
they don't want children
to be able to read and have the
resources to figure that [__] out
they want to dumb down their constituent
constituency and dumb down their
population
and they're gonna do it red state by Red
State by Red State
because folks
they believe alls they have to do
is win a certain amount of states
and they can win
and they can have control and they can
be dictators and tell you what you are
gonna do what you're not gonna do
it's authoritarianism
it's fascism and if you don't know what
those words mean go look the
[__] up if you still have
dictionaries in your state
if you don't
I hope you have access to the internet
so you can go look them up there
because really if you do not know those
words and you do not know what they mean
and it's not clear to you exactly what
is happening
with Ron DeSantis in Florida all the
Republican Governors all over the
country trying to out Florida Florida
and more importantly the Republican
nominee for the president of the United
States
trying to out Hitler Rhonda Ron desantos
I think we'll call him that from now on
Ron desantos
why not
Marjorie De Santos too
and this is clearly a coordinated effort
it's a clear coordinated effort
of manga Republicans
to destroy public education
yesterday Marjorie Taylor green was in a
committee meeting
and she confused an entire State
receiving an amount
for coveted relief funds
because of coven
that was delivered to that state
because there were every state
because they needed money
for education
she confused that within one Elementary
School one
getting five billion with a [__] B
5 billion dollars one Elementary School
let me tell you how many elementary
schools around the country would love to
get a fraction I mean just just [__]
five five million dollars not billion
Jesus Marjorie
they would love to get 500 000 dollars
but Marjorie Taylor green lies to the
American people
in in a official [__] hearing of our
government
while she's questioning someone
about CRT of why this Elementary School
received five billion dollars
for equity and equality
and diversity
she really truly said in front of a
microphone in the camera that one
Elementary School in in [__] Illinois
received five billion dollars
for equity which hey you know what I
actually I'm not against
I'm really truly not against schools
receiving five billion dollars
for Equity equality and diversity
training not against it at all actually
if more schools receive five billion
dollars we wouldn't have rich people
trying to invest in charter schools and
destroying eroding away our [__]
public education system and our
children's [__] minds
for their [__] pocketbooks and their
profit
over [__] voucher system [__] your
voucher system you can take your voucher
system and stick it straight up your ass
and anyone who thinks about your system
is good they can take the voucher system
and stick it straight up their ass
I almost bet
is that a thought here
I bet if you called the elementary
schools
Marjorie Taylor Green's District I
almost bet
if you call the elementary schools in
her District
her constituents the schools that she
represents as a congressperson
almost bet
you would call and ask the question
do you have a lack of funding for school
supplies at your school I I would take a
wild guess that they would say
absofucking lutely
and I bet if if you ask them if I could
help in any way any way shape or form
make sure that you guys have more
funding
for school supplies I bet they'd say
hell to the yeah
hmm
maybe it's not a bad idea
to check and see all these [__]
scumbag Congress people
who were lying about one Elementary
School she didn't say who the elementary
school was in Illinois that received
five billion dollars because it doesn't
exist okay it doesn't exist the truth is
is that the state of Illinois received 5
billion dollars for Education all states
receive money in the covid relief
package for Education because I don't
know they need money for education
it's not it's not it's not [__]
rocket science
and it wasn't just for equity and
diversity
[__] slug Marjorie foot green but I
bet if we called the elementary schools
in her District every [__] one of
them every single God damn one would
need funding for school supplies do you
know how many questions she asked
yesterday do you know how much work I
bet Marjorie Taylor green does in
Congress to make sure that the schools
in her District receive funds
for school supplies did you know did you
know that teachers all around the
country use the pay that we give them
and our public education system to buy
school supplies for their students to
teach them in their classrooms because
they are not provided enough school
supplies even after the parents
the parents are required
to provide school supplies in most
elementary schools there's a [__]
school list that you got to buy all
kinds of [__] school supplies which
most people can't afford anyways as if
school supplies as part of Education or
some [__] ah who to thunk it that's like
their lunches who would who would gather
who would gather the thought that
children would need nutrition to I don't
know learn
foreign
if the build back better Bill do you
remember that the BBB
got killed one of the reasons why I got
killed is because a bunch of dump bucks
in our Congress decided to hold up the
infrastructure bill because they just
wanted more in the BBB
that's and and talking about Democrats
because they just are nothing
it's the Nina Turner way that's right
I'm throwing shots across the bow at
Nina Turner All or Nothing All or
Nothing
the problem wasn't the bill the problem
wasn't that they couldn't get what they
wanted the problem was the messaging and
the narrative
you think you think that parents in this
country no matter who they support
politically want to buy school supplies
for their children
do you think parents in this country no
matter who they support politically want
teachers to have to buy school supplies
in their classrooms for their children
you think that people don't want I mean
there is a small percentage they're
[__] America First Nazi for crying
out loud
you think they don't want nutrition
so that they have the energy and the
brain power
and the proper diet to learn
to become educated adults
do you think
that there's that many people that would
that would absolutely be against school
children starting school at three
instead of five
it's expensive as child care is
you don't think that parents in this
country would want their school-aged
children to start school at three
instead of five that's two years of more
education
and two years less of them having to buy
and pay for daycare and go to work in a
second job just to pay for the daycare
you don't think that's a thing
look these things are not complicated
these narratives these met this
messaging is not complicated it is
really [__] easy we make it difficult
on ourselves
we want to get mired in polls and facts
and statistics
it's really easy
to see the contrast it's really easy
there's choices in this country there's
always choices always choices most the
time you just have a few choices
only a few
only a couple choices that's it
this this Grand [__] delusion that
you have gazillions of choices is really
stupid it's not a thing
human beings are usually faced with one
decision and you got this choice or that
choice
and you can go with the Cheeto Ducks q
and honor with his plan for education to
have the Hitler Youth in this country
or you can choose democracy and Truth
and liberalism because it's not it's not
weakness it is strength
it holds up equity and equality
diversity and if you think those things
are bad if you think equity and equality
and diversity
and and Liberty are bad
you're not a patriot
you're not standing for democracy
you're fighting against it you want a
dictator you want autocracy
so get your [__] head right
get it right and let's do this together
we can fight them
we can win
we are the jury
because he will be their nominee folks
I'm telling you he's gonna be their
nominee I'm gonna give you the proof
today in the [__] list Roundup everyone
thanks for joining us today on the Tony
Michaels podcast I'm glad my my
microphone's working today yesterday
we're having a little technical
difficulties but today we're not because
of that I want you to celebrate by
coming over to the YouTube channel and
subscribing to YouTube we're trying to
get the 20 000 as fast as we can so
share that link around also I want to
thank all
patrons that have went over my patreon
page it's growing every single day it's
growing I'm posting more over there and
I think I'm going to continue to post
more over there to be quite honest I
kind of like the platform now
um I I think it's a good idea I'm gonna
I'm gonna engage over on patreon as much
as I possibly can so go check it out I
have a few more ideas that'll be coming
in the weeks to come
um as as new things over on patreon as
as as you are paying in the 5 10 or 20
dollar tier and we're gonna have new
things coming that are gonna happen in
those tiers so go check it out it's
patreon.com
or just go to thetonymichaels.com
thetonymichaels.com and check out the
patreon page
and when we appreciate your support over
there
we appreciate it right no matter which
tier you're in so I'm gonna try to get
more things more benefits more cool
things that we can engage with
in those tier also download every single
episode of the Tony Michaels podcast
that's important
it's important to the growth of the show
whether it's on Apple Spotify Google
whatever is your favorite directory make
sure to subscribe leave us a great
review and download every single episode
make sure to follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod if you're on Twitter
don't forget this because tonight you're
going to vote for bonehead of the week
you can do it on YouTube so you should
subscribe there you can go to the
community Tab and vote for bone of the
week or on Twitter it'll be a poll and
tomorrow in the second hour
every single Friday we break down the
bonehead of the week where you vote you
decide who is the bonehead of the week
and me and my co-host Gabe Sanchez break
it down
we better get to this I gotta show you
these videos
um and this one of the Cheeto desk you
and honor where he's wanting to and
Institute the Hitler Youth
if he becomes president of the United
States again no he's not we're going to
stand in his way we're gonna fight him
all the way with messaging and narrative
the entire way we will not let him get
away with destroying not only our
country but our children's education
everyone stick around we're gonna go
through these videos right after this
break
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
oh boy I told you um over the summer
you know they especially if uh 20 21
they went on and it's free of CRT
remember the CRT here
2021 where conservatives were absolutely
terrified of three letters the scariest
three letters in that order in the uh
English language CRT
um and they were terrified of it they
they even used it as their wedge in the
uh Virginia Governor's race with youngin
uh and and he got the governorship and
he's doing the exact opposite of what he
promised parents you know and they used
they used the uh the words parent choice
and all this [__] [__] to act like
they act like there's freedom but what
they really mean is they want white
people to have freedom from diversity
and education
and they also want white people to have
freedom from secularism in education
they do not want
a education that is not wrought with
religion and their white Christian
nationalism they definitely do not want
that
um and they know that it's going to be a
very difficult task to do that with the
current public education system they
really tried hard with Betsy DeVos but
with not that much success of destroying
our system I mean our system is not that
great folks the reason why we're in the
situation that we're in anyways is
because our education system really is
in the [__] in this country
I mean you don't believe that that
people here's the thing
as much as we require math and reading
in our in our [__] curriculum we
should require twice as much civics
we should require listen to me when I
say this we should require twice as much
civics
then we do math
people in this country who get out of
high school should know more about the
government before they know about
calculus when they leave high school
that should be a priority it should be a
priority that people know about how our
government works and not just our
federal government
they should know how state governments
operate what state Constitutions are and
the differences most people don't even
know that there is a state constitutions
they don't even [__] know that [__]
they have no idea how our democracy
operates they have no idea why their
day-to-day lives are affected so heavily
by the choices they make at a ballot
they have no [__] clue a good example
is here in Missouri this last 2020
midterm they voted for recreational
marijuana in this state of Missouri
overwhelmingly for recreational
marijuana the same stupid [__]
that went and voted for recreational
marijuana which I'm glad they did that
it only makes sense they voted for Eric
Schmidt as senator who is one of the
most anti-marijuana recreational
marijuana politicians in this country
make it make sense it doesn't it won't
and the only reason why is because we
have failed these people we have failed
ourselves
so yeah do I believe that Civics we
should have way more credits there
should be way more curriculum for civics
from the time that these children in our
school until the time they leave High
School than they ever should
for math or science I know that sounds
[__] crazy I know you're like oh my
God what would we do without Math and
Science let me tell you something if we
don't have Civics and we don't
understand how our democracy works and
how to protect it we won't have math and
science at all I don't know if you're
paying attention they do not want to
[__] teach people how to read in
Florida they do not want kids to read
you have to have [__] books to teach
kids how to read
this is like trying to teach to trying
to teach athletes how to play basketball
without a hoop and a ball
are you going to teach them how to shoot
a jump shot how to dribble a ball
without a hoop and a ball
you're gonna teach children how to learn
without [__] books
their goal is to not teach people and
not teach children how to read
that is their goal
because the people who have the the
means the white folks that have the
means in this country will make sure
their children know how to read
they'll make sure
it's the folks that don't have the means
that rely on our infrastructure that
rely on society as a whole to make the
investment
into our communities by educating
children to make sure they grow up as
adults who use critical thinking skills
logic rational thought
and deductive reasoning
and simply being able how to read
but folks if we do not
if we do not make sure to teach each
other and our children's civics
and how democracy operates not just ours
not just the state constitutions but
democracies around the world
most people have no clue that there's
different systems of democracy that's
why they're like oh we're not into
democracy we're Republic you've heard
that stupid [__] in your comments oh
you're not democracy we're Republic
because they have no idea
they have no [__] clue that there's
different forms of democracy because no
one [__] taught them how to learn
that [__]
nobody
one of the reasons why is because
politicians and state governments and in
the federal government
mainly Republicans the history of
Republicans don't want you to learn
Civics they don't want you to know how
it works why would a bunch of [__]
pro-life people who aren't Pro who claim
to be pro-life who claim that they have
one there's one issue out there abortion
that is the most important issue ever in
the history of ever ever forget about
all the other issues out there forget
about all your other roads forget about
the economy forget about education
forget about health care forget about
any and forget that abortion is Health
Care forget about all that stuff
because if people really knew civics
and they really knew how our democracy
operated do you think there would be a
republican anywhere elected to [__]
anything
[__] no not these modern America First
Nazis they wouldn't have a shot in hell
at a City Council seat let alone a
[__] congressional seat
are are a [__] a United States Senate
seat or a governorship
our secretary of state or an attorney
general of the state they wouldn't have
a [__] chance
if people knew how our democracy works
and how our constitution works and know
that there's just not our Federal
Constitution that their state
constitutions they don't know this
they have no [__] clue
go ask go ask go ask people you know I'm
not just talking about your manga family
and your Maga friends the people who
[__] worship at the altar of dumb
[__] Trump
people don't know how our system of
government and how our democracy Works
they don't know why our institutions are
so [__] strong
that's right our institutions are strong
if you don't believe that then you
weren't paying attention in 2020 and and
the lead up to January 6 and every day
since January 6.
the fabric of our Republic is not weak
and the reason why is because it's woven
with liberalism
with freedom
Liberty is the key yes democracy is
tough especially a two-party system it's
difficult it's difficult to get a lot of
people to agree on one one thing we got
330 million people that we have to get
to agree on issues in this country
that's a f that's a [__] hard thing
especially when we have the selfish
[__] that we have in this
country
but democracy ultimately is the key to
delivering the most equity and equality
we can possibly obtain
it is the key
and who would think who would think that
if that's the key
to making sure that issues in this
country whether it be education
Healthcare whatever the [__] your issue
is
your main issue the thing that that that
bothers you the most who would think
that knowing how our government would
work
and how your vote
Works towards that goal
Who would thought who would think who
who would be learned it enough to
understand that if you knew these things
if we taught our children Civics from
the moment they enter public school I I
I am I am telling you right now I
believe that we have dropped the ball in
this country
by by making sure that math and reading
and science are the number one subjects
they are not because trust me if we
don't teach democracy if we do not treat
teach Civics and why it is so important
to protect it but more importantly teach
them the the opposite of democracy and
what happens
we have it we have it in world history
it's laid out before us
we don't need to guess
on what happens
if we just in this country
had adults
that knew
and know how our democracy works and why
it is so important to protect our
Liberty with our Constitution and why
that is so vital
then we won't be able to teach them Math
Science and reading because folks
they don't want it they want the Hitler
Youth Gabe Sanchez I know you know I'm
going to talk about this video today of
Margaret Taylor green but there's also a
very long video of Donald J uh Hitler I
mean
talking about what his plan is to have
the Hitler Youth in this country and I
know I know people like oh my God you're
saying Hitler a lot today uh you goddamn
right I am right
because that's what needs to be said
this needs to be called out now there's
another video that I really want to
start with though first because we're
going to get into the education thing oh
yeah and why this is so important
um of because
I mean we love to make fun of Donald
Trump oh I'll make yeah all day but I'll
tell you something I'll tell you
something I really think that whoever is
producing these videos for him are
watching our show because it seems like
every critique we give mm-hmm they make
the changes who knows changes man they
might they make the [__] it is
incredible he is getting better and
better and better at producing this
whatever this this um Nazi content is
this set I mean I can tell you I can
tell you for a fact that Liz Harrington
already has me on her radar because of
the announcement you think she's
watching oh that would be eight Legion
yeah give us a shout out Liz if you're
watching I mean we've really if that's
the case we really have upped your game
on this on this on this content that
you're producing for Hitler I mean Trump
I I think I I honestly think that uh
somebody says I look high I don't look
high are you high no I'm not high I
don't know I'm not high you're like no
not today I see I see Karen says Gabe
looks High I'm not high it might be the
lighting but these guys are these did
you drink last night I drank last night
I didn't drink a lot though I just had
it I didn't I just had a few shots of
Jaeger I don't know maybe I should put
some eye drops in during the break or
something
um but I don't I don't think you look
high I think you look you know like
maybe you lost an hour of sleep or
something maybe I don't know I thought I
went to bed earlier than normal oh did
you what time do you usually go to bed
anywhere between like one and two I I
need to get I need to get better I want
to get to life
a lot of people are gonna tell you oh
you need to go to bed early to be
success [__] that [__] you can do the
same [__] now in this day and age at
midnight and one o'clock in the morning
that you can do in [__] five o'clock
in the morning okay it's dark then it's
dark it's dark at midnight it's dark at
four o'clock in the morning there's no
[__] difference there's no difference
in getting up earlier or going to bed
late if you're a night out be a [__]
night be you beat you learn how to live
in that space yeah right if I was high I
would probably not be talking yeah if I
honestly because I'm one of those well
side note we'll just quickly go back to
Trump in a sec if I was actually High
yeah on this show right now
I don't think I would be talking much
and if I did say begin no no not
necessarily are you a gambler when you
get an eye no I'm just like very
introspective
so if I got if I was high in fact on
this show right now I would not be
talking and if I did speak I would have
I would have the fear oh [__] I said too
much oh I can't say anything more so
then I would I would just like not I
would I would not say anything oh well
that wouldn't be good I mean that's the
whole point of the show is right exactly
so if that's why you cannot get on the
show then I would not who wants to see
Gabe high on the show but high on what
well I mean you know whatever I I don't
give a [__] they can decide maybe we
should put up a poll maybe we should put
up a bowl of what Gabe's engine should
he be high on the show and then if you
should be then desk what should he be
high on right yeah that's it I mean look
there's a yeah I've got several
different medicines I can take oh yeah
prescription is that is it or just yeah
we'll call we'll call it prescript
there's just you know different things
right it's like like my Jagermeister
that's prescribed by by a doctor yeah
yeah your local you know your your local
uh mixologist sure doctor at the bar
right the rum the rum and the
Jagermeister are prescribed by a doctor
right anyway but let's get back to Trump
so I don't know I'm having fun with this
conversation everyone knows that on
Thursday on Thursday because I have fun
on Wednesday nights right right Thursday
a lot of times I'm not hungover today
though I didn't have that much I didn't
have that much last night okay I did not
that I didn't have fun great fun okay I
only have like different well I only
have like three shots of Jaeger which is
you know a low amount only and just like
that you just have yeah you're straight
up like that well one of them was with
Red Bull but the other two are just
straight Yeager I I prefer just just to
take a shot of Jager to be quite honest
oh God yeah
no no it's it's great look I'd probably
take Ivermectin over Jaeger anyway oh
really yeah dude [__] that you would eat
horse paste oh yeah you're like yeah
yeah you're like look I'm not a queuing
on her butt yeah look [__] Jager
there are certain things that I will
have and Jaeger ain't one of them really
uh yeah I'm just not a big fan uh well
listen I haven't had a Jager bomb in a
very very long time so who knows bigger
bombs I I like it but the Red Bull as
much as I don't drink energy drinks uh
what do you not like about energy drinks
I just don't need it like the same
reason I don't drink coffee right people
get very weird yeah that's so [__]
weird that's so weird it's like what
kind of monster are you you don't drink
coffee this is ridiculous he drinks
bubbly water I drink yeah I drink it I
drink people don't know OJ Tangerine
juice you know Tanger ranges yeah
lemonade but I don't have that as much
of it but it's basically just water wait
wait do you do you do Kool-Aid do you
mix Kool-Aid Kool-Aid I'm not a kid man
what what I haven't what's wrong I
haven't had a Kool-Aid since I was a kid
oh my God
this [__] game this let me tell you
you know who does drink the Kool-Aid ah
well we're gonna find out yeah I'm sure
today on the shitless Roundup well
here's the thing one more thing before
we get on the [__] list here
um the Roundup because I got there's
like three videos and I'm sure it's
gonna take up
the whole second hour I'm just sure of
it because these [__] boneheads we're
gonna have to break down this this
Hitler education Trump youth thing well
line by line but um when I was sick
because I was sick for a couple weeks
you know I had the sinus issues and I
had the cough like I was muting my
microphone like every two seconds right
and that you're doing free promotion for
looted right you both had it all sitting
here I just picked up a bag of ludens
because oh okay well so you never know I
did find and and I'm not I'm not that
again I don't get paid for Jagermeister
this is not a paid promotion or anything
but listen when I was coughing that
Jagermeister because it's it's like
cough syrup and if anyone doesn't know
it's it tastes like the green almost
like the green NyQuil if you've never I
don't take NyQuil so I don't know I love
NyQuil and probably because I like the
taste but it is like taking a shot you
yeah you'd take a shot and wouldn't need
ludens wouldn't need halls I just
coached the throat and well the throat
the stomach and you can feel it go all
the way down and it's almost like
there's a and there's like a party all
the way up you know there's like a party
inside your stomach when it gets I don't
know of that you know how there's like
yeah fine there's like parties but like
maybe it's not the best blankets oh this
is a Rowdy party cops are called we
gotta get everyone out of the party so
when so when so when you you know like
you have like a fire pit outside you
know and it's kind of chilly and you
throw it on and that that Heat's coming
off that and everyone's having fun and
singing and maybe doing Kumbaya whatever
you're doing around you're just drinking
NyQuil before you do karaoke
well I mean it's Jager but I mean oh
well yeah sure Jaeger I mean I might I I
don't know that I should drink NyQuil
before karaoke because I'd be like
you know I'd be sleeping right all right
there's a little more sleeping agents
than there is Jagermeister I'm just
saying that Jagermeister was not bad at
helping my throat and cough that's all
I'm saying okay okay don't knock it
until you try it until you get wasted on
it or hung over on the show from it
everyone it's time to round up all the
Tweety tweets and drinks enough of the
not the Jagermeister nonsense uh let's
let's surf the Tweety tweets and Trinity
Trends in the [__] list Roundup start
the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh [__]
um uh did you know that Nikki Haley's
gonna announce that she's running for
president or she thinks they're all
going behind his back
well here's the thing is and I've been
saying this we talked about this on the
show these people are Rhonda Santos is
not gonna run I mean unless unless a guy
jokes on like a [__] cheeseburger or
something
yeah like he again he just got sworn in
you know re re-elected last month right
officially yeah but what the hell is
that got to do anything well I would
very much doubt that
he's going to announce any anything in
February I think you think you think
Rhonda Santos wouldn't wouldn't take
advantage if he knew he could take
advantage come on look George Ronald
desantos would definitely I'm gonna go
into Santos from now on [__] I I don't
know now you can understand why I said
it one time on the show it just slipped
out you know to say that to Santos you
know and then also uh Lindsey Graham
yesterday we're watching the clip and
boom to Santos but
um he said to Santos yeah he said it
during his thing and then you started I
think oh yeah or two days ago maybe when
we were when we had uh Rhonda Santos but
he said Rhonda said he's like can you
imagine if we can get if we can get just
the majority of the population in the
country to refer to Ron DeSantis as De
Santos I mean believe that that's his
[__] name I mean well I mean let's
let's face it Rhonda Rhonda Santos is
way way more of a fraud and a liar than
George saying oh yeah yeah yeah way
[__] 100 listen I I I really don't
appreciate people saying that George
Santos making [__] up about his his dead
mother is way more detrimental to our
democracy than what Ron DeSantis is
lying about with with education and
reading in Florida give me a [__]
break that's way more detrimental to our
society and our education so get spare
me spare me your [__] snowflake tears
about about Santa toes and his little
[__] stupid lies about oh this is my
name and this my mom died this time and
I mean whatever crimes and financial
crimes he committed great whatever
[__] yeah we'll we'll deal with that
but to act like those lies are more
detrimental and we should be calling for
him to resign over Rhonda Santos give me
a [__] break give me a break this guy
that's the reason why Trump really had
to make this video right that's why you
had to make videos every day and oh
that's what that was you know before we
got off on the tangent before Oh about
the yeah yeah yeah exactly I don't want
to get off on a tangible
let's get back to the Kool-Aid drinking
yeah so uh the real I mean a big reason
that he's making these videos which I
think also
is they they they leave him in that room
for hours on end to do multiple takes
because these videos are like 15 seconds
20 seconds 30 seconds some are a few
minutes
but a lot of these are like
uh he's completely like crooked Hillary
Clinton
Joe Budden
you know or he's like do you think
have like um
like just uh already written lines and
they just record those lines and then
they cut them I know like I can die and
[__] no I can tell you for a fact that
he does read
he's reading off a teleprompter that's
oh you're saying you can read or he is
reading well I mean he can you know he
can put words together and then he just
fills in a blank and the blank usually
is some random tangent or rant about
something unrelated and he's like and
that was the time I was voted most
popular in high school and it's like
that had nothing to do with this right
but the idea that he is he is reading
off a teleprompter he has given he has
given a response to go through and I
think that they're realizing
uh while he does have longer ones right
which we're gonna watch a long one today
yeah yeah that's like the four minute
clip right right it's the one about how
he's gonna you know indoctrinate our
children right but what they've realized
is if you go through his you know if you
if you if you if you dare uh go on a
journey through his truth Social account
you'll realize that that's why we do it
for you it's rough and you can also
watch him on Rumble too but you can
realize that what he does is they have
15 20 30 second up to a minute Clips are
more are happening more often now
because I think what they've realized is
they're like great if we can just like
set the box right here and say like this
is what you have to say if he goes onto
a tangent it won't be that long but
literally the line is like three
sentences
and then boom we're just gonna play the
Trump 2024 make America great again well
you know I think I think they took our
advice and maybe Liz is listening and
Liz congratulations on taking our advice
because one of the sets of advice we
gave them from this content that he's
making is that um what they they didn't
know it didn't seem like they knew that
they could cut the [__] where he goes
off on a dent like it's a video right
you could just cut that part out like
you don't you can just whip it and that
part where he's saying stupid [__] that
has nothing to do with the script that
you gave him you can just cut that part
out like yeah a thing you can do and
really if you set up two or three
cameras which is what they've done I
think it's a two camera setup that
they've got yeah yeah well they
sometimes they switch but yeah if you do
if you do multi-shot it makes your
editing way easier then you can take one
and you just switch and and you know and
it doesn't even look like he is going on
a tangent right I I appreciate that
they're listening to us at least at
least giving his content you know the
ability where we're just [__]
breaking down his words and what he's
saying as opposed to Jesus Christ your
color saturation is horrible your
lighting is different each time what the
[__] are you doing he's Way Off Script
you you know you can edit these videos
right they're like he's Way Off Script
where a million dollars over budget you
know it's just that's how much how much
how much grifting money do you think
they've spent and because I know it's
probably a situation where he has set up
a production company like himself
probably like like um um not Trump
production companies LLC and Delaware or
some [__] and then and then that's the
production company that he's hired these
people through so that he can pay
himself
um the production I almost bet that's
what he's doing well he hasn't I can
tell you this much I just checked my
burner number and uh Trump has not
texted
[Music]
or text
is it like is it like he sends a text
Goose me some mice and mooses yeah he's
like President Trump McConnell blue yeah
but I'm talking about the word texted is
that a word yeah
well he texted me well I know do you say
text it or he texted me no if I'm gonna
text somebody texted just like I don't
say salsa I say salsa you said he texted
me what the [__] is a grammar he texts
me yes caveman he fixed Me Caveman yeah
he texted me it's past tense but if you
go oh yeah he texted me you sound you
sound illiterate
I am what the [__] this is an indictment
of our public education system okay why
why is it wrong wait wait a second wait
a second why is it wrong here's a good
example texted he hate me
he hated me he texted me he texted me he
hated me meaning he doesn't hate me now
you could say he hate me yeah
[__] he hates me
listen I don't know if you people
realize this but I'm from Missouri and
there ain't a [__] a on that goddamn
States spelling I'm from Missouri okay
and I'm from the hills of Missouri where
we say salsa you know who also probably
we're sure we wash our clothes we don't
wash them we worship you you know who
also probably says he texts me who Trump
yeah sure that that's probably about
right I would say that's about right all
right so he hasn't texted you in a while
he has not sent me a text in a while
right he hasn't texted you in a while
the 26th and I just I just checked in to
say hello to be like oh is it still
working like am I I haven't responded to
any of these messages send him a text
back did you get any response and then
yeah and then they just sent me a text
that says thanks for your message will
you vote for Donald J Trump in 2024.
maybe
uh maybe I don't want to say no just in
case they kick me from yeah right right
they don't yeah right you want to keep
getting the uh right the goods right you
want to keep yeah I still need these
messages but he hasn't he hasn't said
it's important in a few days which is
very very
it is kind of weird I would I would
imagine you're gonna get one about Nikki
Haley soon and here's why
um Nikki Haley is uh supposed to
announce that she's gonna run for
president uh against Donald Trump
because remember folks uh the election
that is going on right now uh because
Donald Trump announced he's running is a
Republican primary so the only
competition here is between Republicans
that's it that's it so they got to fight
each other well uh we know we we we
showed um uh his truth poster fraud
social post the other day where he
called uh Ron desantos Ron de Saint
demonius and he claimed he was a
globalist which is [__] laughable I
mean he's also just reusing old names
well right well and he's just he's like
oh run run to sanctimonious is a Marxist
like Okay
um this is really weird you know we're
in la la land here but but Nikki Haley
is supposed to announce now
um obviously Nikki Haley will never be
president of the United States She is
totally unqualified to be president
United States and and the one reason why
she's totally unqualified to be
president of the United States is one
reason one reason only that I need is
that she genuflected to Trump
um that's what to me that's what
disqualifies her and she's willing to
sell out her entire [__] country her
oath uh she's willing to sell it her
country the Constitution to gen inflect
to Trump and he actually posts the video
here he posts the video the evidence of
it
um which is [__] crazy
um but he threatens her uh he does
threaten her here now I said Nikki Haley
is about to end her career as a
republican what do I mean by that and I
put quotes around it for a reason I use
that Republican
um as on purpose here
um Nikki Haley will will probably never
be elected to any Republican seat ever
again after this this is it for Nikki
Haley she will not be a politician she's
already been a governor she's been in as
part of the Trump Administration with
the U.N
um she will not be a elected Republican
ever again she just destroyed her career
um that is if she if she does announce
that she's running because here's what I
said the cult leader will destroy her
and here's the evidence now
I believe Gabe Sanchez oh here I am once
again I believe Gabe Sanchez that this
is evidence of why Ron DeSantis is also
not going to run
um he's not going to race unless Grandpa
chokes on a cheeseburger or keel's over
dead while he's you know trying to swing
his golf club
um Ron DeSantis is not going to enter
the race for this reason and the reason
that we showed the other day where he
called him a globalist which is again
they love throwing that name any
anywhere
in this video that we're going to show
but any any Republican uh I mean you
know we saw it from people like um Alex
Stein confronting uh Ted Cruz and he's
like he's a globalist and Danny Crenshaw
he dog called Dan Crenshaw any Republic
like you know it is this rhino globalist
you know
anti-maga agenda that they they see
other people have if you don't agree
with what Trump does and you don't agree
with the policies that Trump has then
you're a globalist you're Rhino you're
anti this and anti that and you're not
American you're not a patriot but that's
the point of a cult though yeah
a
a wide range of Shades like we do have
in the Democratic party right you've
everything from you know we talked about
yesterday they never trumpers the you
know The Independents the leftists the
libs all this like you have a wide range
of how people classify themselves but on
the right you really only have two and
it's
actual conservatives actual Republicans
and then you've got just like Maga no
but I would argue that you don't even
have the conservative Republicans oh
yeah I mean they're the globalist and
they're right yeah yeah but even then
like I'm gonna I'm gonna group them all
I'm gonna call them all I'm gonna say
look if you're you know it's the same
thing you got you know 10 Nazis at a
table and you're one of them you got 11
Nazis right that's right well we've said
that time and time again and to to think
that Nikki Haley or Ron DeSantis or some
sort of globalist because they may they
may consider challenging Trump is is
awesome I mean this is the wedge that we
need to defeat Trump in 2024 because he
will be their nominee and this is proof
of it um he posted this this morning
um again I want to point out did you see
how he changed his um his avatar on yeah
it looks like his face is uh thing right
yeah yeah I mean his foot it's it's it's
a flag that is overlaid on his face and
it has the most of it right but it also
makes his face look fat like a [__]
uh looks like a Pancake Man
it looks like he's just like totally
dripping down like that's what it looks
like like a like a melted ice cream cone
yeah kind of but it looks like um
it looks like putty he looks like [__] I
mean yeah it looks like [__] yeah yeah
let's go what it is but it looks like
this is hard it's like I'll smear his
art and someone did this art they could
have at least did the whole like uh
remember when they were pasting his his
head on this um on the Rambo cut out
yeah yeah the CPAC is it Patriot phone
or some [__] some stupid [__] Trader
Network or something that's the whole
thing yeah but but they but they that's
where that came from and it it got went
viral on the internet that these people
were posing with this cardboard cutout
of Rambo with his face superimposed on
it but you you think they could at least
do something like that but they didn't I
mean if Nikki Haley I mean if uh Liz
Harrington is listening yeah if you're
gonna do a profile photo you want to
have space oh right this is just this is
just aesthetic of photos right this is
like design 101 yeah yeah you want to
have space around the object right
whatever your subject is being your face
so that you can get perspective and not
have this smushed face that takes up the
whole thing it looks like it looks like
you're [__] just a fat smudge against
a wall
oh man you know what we should take this
and and and undo the um the flag and
make him a blueberry pancake or
something I'm just saying okay so so
this he posted this video now the reason
why he posted this video is because it
was pointed out to him by Newsmax I
believe yesterday
um because the story was breaking
yesterday that Nikki Haley is going to
announce sometime in February to run for
president United States on the
Republican ticket right
um and I think Newsmax yesterday they
played this clip on one of their Trader
TV shows
um so he lifts the clip and he puts it
on his broad Social account this morning
and he says the following
Nikki has to follow her heart
not her honor she should definitely run
exclamation point and this is the video
this is the sound
um because it's really a video but this
is um and I believe this is from 20
20 after
or is it from last year and I don't know
I'm not sure exactly when this run but
she is answering questions about Trump
running in 2024. that is the most
important part about this is this
question about Trump running in 2024
listen runs again in 2024 will you
support him yes
if he decides that he's going to run
would that preclude any sort of run that
you would possibly make yourself I would
not run
it so um Nikki desantos here
um decides that she's going to lie
um and run anyways now here's my guess
because
um he is absolutely destroyed her here
and he's he's threatening to destroy you
he's like she should run I'll [__]
destroy her like he he is if she goes
ahead with this you are you are
absolutely going to see the reason why
Rhonda santis will never enter this race
as long as Donald Trump has his [__]
sheep with him there's no [__] way if
to hurt a sheep is with Donald Trump
that Ron DeSantis will enter the race
especially if Nikki Haley gets in and he
burns her house to the ground now just a
little bit of history on Nikki Haley um
Nikki Haley was the governor in South
Carolina uh she likes to hold the credit
for taking the Confederate Battle Flag
down from the capital grounds there is
some sort of oh that's that's her claim
to wokism fame yeah right and they're
going to use that [__] that he's going
to use that [__] against her I bet you I
bet you a lot of [__] money and I'm
not a bet man that if Nikki Haley does
actually enter this race one of the
first things that you're going to see
Trump and his his allies and and the and
the and the [__] trolls and the
thread these goddamn Nazis on Twitter
and and on fraud social the one thing
you're gonna see them do is attack her
for removing that Confederate Battle
Flag from the capitol grounds in South
Carolina that is the one thing that they
will attack her on and they will win
that fight because these people are
[__] deluded they're delusional now a
little more history a little more
history on the Gailey because I want to
tell you why she thinks she can run
um she went to the the um Iowa straw
poll okay she was in the Iowa straw poll
uh in 2016. uh I believe or 2020. she
was in one of the straw polls and she
did really well in this Rubble
um as well as a republican could do
that's why she thinks she has a chance
she didn't have a [__] shot in hell
yeah she's she's dead in the water this
this [__] this one post this one post
right here from Grandpa Poopypants the
Cheeto dust q and Honor on true social
even as shitty as true social is this is
the death nail in her presidential
candidacy this one [__] post I
mean telling her I I I dare you to enter
the race I dare you yeah it's um
because he he also pulled out another
clip and I don't and I wasn't able to
look up where like when or where it was
from but it was uh it was Ron DeSantis
being asked questions and he was talking
about him as a leader and it was just
like a you know he it wasn't uh let me
see if I can find it yeah yeah well why
you're doing that um
and uh speaking of Ron DeSantis and
education and uh Donald Trump trying to
out Hitler Ronda Santos I want to go
real quick why you're looking for that
clip um to another uh America First Nazi
which is Marjorie Taylor green holy [__]
this clip oh my god listen I cannot
believe I cannot believe that they
thought it was a good idea for her to
try to sit and ask real questions to
real Witnesses on committees it is but
this is I mean you know we we talked
about it with uh with Rachel right like
it's uh Dr Rachel bidikoffer and it
really does expose them as idiots
they're gonna spend the next two years
doing nothing complaining about [__]
stuff but also the things that they say
and this clip is a good example as like
you're like [__] first up to bat and
this is what you come to the plate with
right you you are it's it's only going
to be downhill from here for anything
that the Republican party wants to do I
mean they just kicked ilhan Omar out of
the uh the foreign um subcommittee so
they got you know they got their revenge
on her
um because that's what well and even and
even
um
um you watch Matt gatz
um use
um there what is they consider Omar's
anti-Semitism which I don't believe
that's the angle
um that um her rhetoric is but
um they used it Matt gas was even like
well I'm I'm considering not removing
her because she's with MaGa on some of
these issues so I mean you gotta really
you got to really read between the lines
of some of this [__] but this this clip
here
um is Marjorie Taylor green now the
reason why this has to do with the Trump
video is because this I believe is a
coordinated effort
um this was Donald Trump's effort to get
Marjorie Taylor green to ask these
stupid [__] questions and say these
stupid [__] lies uh in front of a
microphone in the committee to try to
push this video that he's gonna tell you
about
are that that we're going to show you
this is all a coordinated app now it's a
really horrible one Liz Harrington if
you're listening you [__] this up bad
like you really [__] this up I don't
know who thought this was a good lie to
tell but today everyone including
Republicans are laughing at Marjorie
Taylor green and and have now eroded
what if there is any seriousness that
you took her I mean I don't have
anything to erode I don't know was there
anyone who actually took her seriously
right even in the Republican party right
like was there anyone that looked at her
and was like yeah wow he's actually
bringing something to the table Kevin
McCarthy put her on this [__]
committee so I mean yeah he put her on
the committee because he's literally uh
well he has a tour right you know
they're taking selfies after the vote oh
we got it Kevin we got it you're right
now buddy I own you and meanwhile in his
head he's like [__] [__] [__] okay
and he has to go through with it because
of course you know he is tied to that
one one Republican whoever might be to
say uh I call a vote right to challenge
Kevin McCarthy's uh speakership and the
Democrats are like yeah okay cool yeah
let's do it you know you want to go
through the [__] again let's do it right
well and and I think this video of
Margaret take the green
uh when you look at it through the
context and the lens of the video the
other video that we're going to show you
of trump talking about describing how he
wants to have the Hitler Youth in this
country and how he's going to Institute
um that like they did in 1930s 1940s
Germany
um and it's almost like he read someone
read him those books he's like hey
that's a really great idea let's do it
like that
um but how um this is Trump's House of
Representatives yeah Kevin McCarthy is
not the Speaker of the House Trump
controls Kevin McCarthy Trump controls
uh these these Maga members of the house
he controls them full stop it is his
house that's why I actually
um after this clip and after seeing um
the Trump video this morning I actually
believe that Trump is going to make sure
that we default on her debt I I think
he's going to do everything in his power
to make sure that the Republicans do not
raise the debt limit and we default on
our debt he wants he wants something to
be destroyed he wants chaos he wants to
create and manufacture a crisis
um so he can say I could I'm the only
one that can fix it right right I mean
that's the idea and I do believe I do
believe that is going to happen
um I'm convinced of it after these clips
I do think we're going to default on our
debt folks be prepared for that I I
really do and I actually do think that
we're going to shut down our government
in September for probably eight nine
months if not all the way till the 2024
election is done and completed I think
we're going to shut down government
um because that's what Trump is going to
want and he's going to direct these
fools to do it and by fools I mean this
one here
um and the reason why this [__] clip
it's got almost 5 million views just off
this one
it's she's so stupid I mean what a
[__] idiot it's pretty do you think
do you think because you've seen this
club do you think
that she really believes this stuff
because someone told her I think she's a
[__] idiot and she didn't actually
and I can give context once we play it I
can give people contact us too okay
because it's not very long it's not very
long so let's listen to a few of the
lies that she tells because almost
everything that comes out of her mouth
is a lie in this clip right and remember
that's why I keep saying folks this
decent or excuse me George Santos not
Ronda Santos but George Santos is not an
outlier in the lies that he or tell he's
telling is not as detrimental to our
democracy is the lies that all the other
Republicans tell all the other
Republicans lied to their constituents
defrauded their constituents to become
members of the house like this one here
let's listen can you tell me uh how much
how much coveted cash with the CRT
it's CRT
okay I wanted to play the whole thing
but I got to stop it here because she
she says she is such a [__] bonehead
that she doesn't even know she doesn't
even know the piece of legislation the
name of it yeah and and she calls it
covered cash like she's on like she's on
[__] Tucker Carlson's show or some
[__] she doesn't even know the bill that
that that the United States legislator
passed in the president United States
signed to give these relief funds to
education in States because I don't know
states are actually in charge of their
education inside their their
constitutions but I also like just he's
like sorry what what well well look at
the screen like this SnapChat
he's like huh right I'm sorry come again
right well number one is because she did
not refer to it as it's as its official
piece of legislation right because she
is she's working off the cuff here she's
not scripted she doesn't know how to do
this at all she's horrible at this and
one reason why she's horrible at this
and this is to all the constitu her
constituents down in her District in
Georgia the reason why she's horrible at
this is because she's an unserious
person and she hasn't actually been your
congressperson for the two years prior
she did none of this she wasn't aware of
this her staff doesn't know how to do
this because they didn't have to do this
[__]
so they don't know how to get into a
official Committee hearing and to
actually question a [__] witness that
is in front of them to help you
constituents a murder day the green but
let's let's continue because it gets it
the lies get even Wilder here now
outside the CRT critical race Theory and
education it's it's a racist uh
curriculum used to teach children uh
that somehow their white skin is not
equal to black skin and other things
okay so she gives it away she gives away
the game of exactly because she doesn't
know what CRT is and she doesn't
actually know how to describe it she
wasn't ready
to have to try to describe it to him so
basically she went off the cuff and
she's based she basically said I don't
like CRT because it's racist against
white people and black people want to
want to be racist towards black are
white people that's exactly what she's
saying
it's it's Insanity she is it's look
there's dumb and then there's uh
Marjorie Taylor green okay this is
someone I mean we can here we'll play
the rest of the clip and then I'll sure
lay down some facts on this let's
there's only 27 seconds but I'm sure I'm
gonna have to stop the for another
[__] lie yeah uh no I do not know
that but I I do know that there's
Provisions that the uh federal funds
generally are not used they're supposed
to be used for curriculum oh that's a
statement oh Mr Darrow I have to tell
you okay so so he's trying what he's
trying to do is tell her that in the
legislation if she would have read it
like when she had the opportunity to
vote on it and since then since her
state would receive some of these funds
and her constituency that [__]
schools in her District receive these
funds folks
they received These funds these evil
demonic communist funds now she she's
she's gonna talk about a blue State here
but again before she tells this lie I
understand that her District the schools
the public schools and the children in
her district and her communities
received these demonic communist coveted
cash funds let's listen in Illinois that
they received 5.1 billion
um at an elementary school there that
that used it for equity and diversity
um oh so it's being used for these
things uh Mr dinero can you oh my God I
cannot tell you how bad she is at this
like when you're when you're questioning
right if you're on um and I don't I
don't know if anyone's
um ever done debate or anything but if
you've ever watched
um a very really good policy maker ask
questions in a Committee hearing to get
answers uh for their constituents you
need to go watch Katie Porter Katie
Porter is one of the best at this she is
she is a professional she's a very
serious serious policy maker and she
knows that when she has a witness before
her that she is there to work for her
constituents to get answers to questions
that her constituents need to know like
that that's and she is she designs her
entire questioning around those answers
that she's looking for Marjorie Taylor
green is doing whatever Republican does
which is not get answers they're looking
for a sound bite and she hasn't
practiced this at all and not only that
her staff is horrible at this so give us
the context of the lies behind this
whole it won't there's an Illinois
elementary school that got 5 billion
with a B point one billion you know
what's cool billion with a B right even
0.1 billion is ridiculous so okay this
is so D I just want okay first off first
off I just want to point point out the
fact that she goes oh Mr odero let me
tell you like she's about to lay down
this gotcha moment right or dodara or
dodaro sorry yeah and she thinks she's
gonna have a Katie Porter moment here
right right and she yeah she's like oh
let me tell you you don't know what's
coming actually a school in Illinois got
5.1 billion dollars for CRT that's
[__] wrong what happened was the
state no this is crazy a whole state
right a whole state in the shape of this
pretty much this is the shape of
Illinois right here it is it is kind of
shaped like a hand there's this and then
there's Wisconsin but it's a big it's a
big hand it's a big hand not a tiny hand
yeah it's a big you know it's a you know
Illinois right first perspective
Illinois much bigger than this what
happened was the state the whole state
of Illinois
got five point or got five billion
dollars right are they the only state
that got this money because it feels
like when she's saying this they're the
only state that got Tony Tony Tony Tony
Tony Tony
are you gonna are you gonna tell me
facts
okay all 50 states got money
whoa you mean
you mean you mean you mean
excuse me excuse me please wait okay uh
what happened was okay all 50 states all
of them okay all 50 states
the United States of America got 81
billion
dollars
are you saying one elementary school in
the United States got anyone are the
entirety of the United States
one elementary school that is built out
of kale yeah and and run by lib pink
pink haired libtards yeah
one Elementary School that only teaches
one course which is socialism no
critical race critical race Theory no
all 50 states in America if I forgot you
know that we have 50.
um 81 billion dollars and it was part of
the American Rescue plan the elementary
and secondary school relief program okay
who passed this by the way I want to
know who passes oh I don't know it got
passed in 2021. well that well well that
would mean that would mean that's why
this is a wokism bill that's why that's
why they received all this woke funds
for uh CRT because it was passed under
the world the mother wokers yeah so it
was a
they received a 5 billion in Illinois
the State Illinois the state okay okay
so Illinois received 5 billion or over 5
billion dollars wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait so
you're telling me that the Illinois gave
it all to this one elementary school
because that yeah yeah it sounds like
what she's saying okay
so oh my God she's such a [__] so
they gave the state of Illinois 5
billion over 5 billion dollars in
education funding during the second
round of the covid-19 relief funding
that happened in 2021 yeah it didn't go
to one Elementary School it was split
from
851 school districts in Illinois and
that's you know wait how many how many
851 school districts no there can't be
that many woke districts in them we're
saying I'm just saying I'm just saying
wait wait are you saying now now is it
only the districts that were that were
run and operated by pink haired
communist and I know I keep saying pink
hair comments but you folks are going to
understand what what I mean by that here
in a little bit uh no it was actually
everyone you know oh uh it's crazy
there's like you mean even like in
Republican counties and Republicans
especially
Republican counties wait a second I bet
and I I brought this up the first 30
minutes I bet if we called down to
Marjorie Taylor Green's District the
elementary schools in her district and
asked them ask them look we need to know
do you need money for school supplies it
really feels like most schools do and is
there anything we can do to help they
would be like yeah what the thing you
can do is give us money and and my next
question would be did you guys receive
some of that covet cash did you get some
of that dirty commy money and I bet
their answer would be yeah but that
shit's long gone I mean education cost a
lot of [__] yeah it cost a lot of
[__] money would be pretty surprised
how much the money goes to resources for
it's a big investment it's a big
investment paying the salaries of
teachers who have to you know do more
work than than they would normally
because of the pandemic especially when
we go to voucher systems and we have to
make sure that the charter schools get
profit for their investors exactly you
know you got that old thing it's a it's
a it's a [__] [__] to fund an
education it's pretty crazy what happens
when uh you look at the facts because
the facts are the complete opposite of
what Marjorie Taylor green said well
obviously there would also and let's
also just keep clearing this is just for
coveted this is covid-19 related funding
for one piece of legislation that's just
yeah this is just to help schools with
resources and and payment you know for
other things that require uh to create a
learning experience
um you know supplies whoa whoa what you
mean children have to learn in schools
yeah dude they gotta they gotta learned
you know they got to learn that stuff
and uh if they don't learn to do this
stuff then they didn't learn to then
they'll say [__] like that he text he
texted me he texts me say [__] so yeah
it has nothing to do with CRT critical
race Theory which again is a law school
level
education Theory well the other one
details well go go ahead CRT yeah
critical race Theory yeah is a law
school level education Theory so you're
saying you're saying that it's not
taught in the schools that we're seeing
this they're not teaching this to kids
who are in kindergarten right now like
Hey we're going to teach you how to
create a socialist type of society
between communist exactly a bunch of
pink characters
um well let's let's just go to that
video
um because I I wanna this is gonna take
a while we're at the bottom of the
second hour so we're gonna run out of
time on this one because it's almost
five minutes long
um this is this is from Grandpa poopy
pants they posted this now again we're
not gonna have to spend too much time
Liz on your uh production of this video
um if you're listening because you're
getting better at it you're taking our
tips but we'll give you a few tips maybe
your production will get a little better
I find it funny that the um the the the
the the uh what do you call this in
design where they use the The Faded
thing with the with the logo and then
they got a picture yeah well the picture
because the picture here is a picture of
when he was in the Oval Office so he's
trying to pretend like he's the
president already right yeah yeah uh not
sure what this picture is from but it
just it's just a I don't know like uh
it's a title correct right but I mean I
don't know but what do you call when
they when you come on man what do you
think it's like a subliminal message
here
you see what I mean yeah yeah yeah yeah
I mean yeah I don't know it's just I
guess it's a messaging tactic yeah okay
I mean I don't know what you would call
that specifically Liz it's good on you
because I noticed it all right let's
let's start watching this because again
I'm gonna have to pause it for all the
lies and I can't pause for every single
line
because it's it's five minutes of him
talking so I mean we'd have to pause it
would be four hours this show so here we
go
our public schools have been taken over
by the radical left Maniacs okay like
like I like right out of the gate right
out of the gate he number one Liz he's
manix
it Liz really honestly if you're gonna
cut like and you're doing a fade anyways
you can just you don't have to cut where
he takes the first [__]
right you could you could cut that out
but but but he goes straight in
straight in for the liberal Maniacs
thing right I mean he's gonna go for the
[__] the throat you know you might as
well go for it
[Applause]
he's he's really setting the tone here
of what this video is going to be about
the liberal Maniacs right okay let's
let's see what the liberal Maniacs are
gonna do because I'm sure it's not
projection of what he wants to do I'm
sure
here is my plan to save American
Education restore power to American
parents first we will cut Federal
funding for any school or program
pushing critical race theory gender
ideology or other inappropriate racial
sexual or political content onto our
children okay so no school
will receive federal funding that has
that talks about CRT or gender genitalia
or sexualizing children so basically the
only schools that are not going to
receive Public Funding are Republican
ones because those are the ones that are
totally [__] enamored with this
[__] of CRT and gender ideology and
and wokeism I mean they're the ones that
are hammering out these details like
actual school districts that are serious
about this stuff are not [__] talking
about CRT and wokeism they're just I
don't know educating children so right
out of the 80s telling you and here's
what he's saying in this I believe is
that no Department of Education no
federal dollars will go to schools your
children are not going to receive your
tax dollars in their education system
well yeah I mean we we saw that from
Betsy you know Betsy DeVos where she was
the one who was already you know like we
got to go to the we got to go to a a
chart order we got to go to
um yeah yeah
um yeah we have to go to a voucher
option we we can't have funding to
public schools and then you've got
basically then what and then here's
here's the reality of it people don't
know how this happens you say okay we're
going to a charter or we're going to a
voucher system right
and yeah sure some people from certain
areas might be to have the privilege of
going there and they you know they'll
get more funding than a public
institution will but what happens is
when you start cutting students out from
a district and you say okay well there's
five less here we're gonna put them over
there and there's like 10 less here
we're gonna put them over here and
they're moving them into this voucher
system or they're reallocating where the
student goes because just like
redistricting redistricting happens with
voting it can also happen with schools
right so you can literally live across
the street from a school and you would
think hey I go to that school and they
go no no your school is actually five
miles away
so what happens is by reallocating
resources and where the students go then
what happens is you essentially close
down a school so now you have you you
don't have enough resources you don't
have enough teaching and you don't have
enough students in that school to
justify it being open right so then what
happens is you now have students going
other places and randomly where have you
and you have an overpopulation at
schools we're now where now teachers
have even less funding and less
resources and schools have less teachers
to teach more students because now
instead of having a class of I don't
know 10 15 something that's normal for a
learning environment they now have 30 40
students you know you're getting into
the same type of situation that you
would find in a college level course
where you have a large group of people
right you have a large number of
students but in in those classes you
have Tas and assistance and other people
that can help out
um and also you have things that are
available online but when it comes to
Public Schools elementary schools
secondary schools they want to cut the
funding and then they just create this
um
essentially they they create its own
failure right they they re they
redistrict they reallocate sources and
then by the end they say Oh see it was
never meant to be in the first case in
the first place like it was already
gonna already it's meant to fail well
and I also want to point out his
messaging here because I think it was uh
I don't know three or four months ago uh
Betsy DeVos speaking of her came out and
said we should abolish the word abolish
the Department of Education yeah um and
it was a big uproar they were like oh my
God and then a few other people kind of
said it but what he's doing is he's
practicing messaging here so he's saying
there's going to be no federal funding
to schools right now he's putting
stipulations on it but what what he
means is is when I'm the dictator and
I'm the king I get to decide who gets
the funding is what he's saying it's
literally what he's saying because
a president United States does not have
the power to pick and choose which
schools get which money states have the
power folks States that's why that's why
the state of Illinois received the 5.1
and then they decided where that money
would go in the districts the 800 and
some odd districts not the federal
government the federal government gives
the states the money the states allocate
those funds in the state now now the
federal government can put stipulations
on what those funds can go towards but
they get to decide which schools the
federal government and the [__]
president United States does not get to
decide which schools get it and which
schools don't it's a [__] lie and
what he's telling you in that in this
[__] clip just the phrase he said
when he's like oh we're not gonna we're
gonna make sure no federal funding goes
towards uh
schools with pink cared Communists which
is going to be another Trend here in the
video
um essentially what he's saying is I'm
gonna pick and choose he's already
telling you he's going to be dictator
and he's going to dictate like the
Hitler Youth let's continue with his
little
stupidity here but let's go we're not
going to allow it to happen next I will
direct the Department of Justice and
education
to open civil rights investigations into
any school district that has engaged in
race-based discrimination okay so here
again here again this is the [__]
projection when they say Democrats and
Biden and the doj are weaponized against
you and your school and your children
and parents they're saying they want to
have gazpacho soup police okay that is
what he's saying here he's saying he's
going to weaponize the federal
government to make sure that if you
believe a certain thing in a certain way
that you do not get to work in the
education system or God forbid we allow
people to have you know Equity right
right equality wow that way
whoa that would be disgusting if anyone
in this country had Equity inequality
besides white people okay listen that is
disgusting Gabe Sanchez that you would
even suggest such a woke thing like that
you mother woker Okay so but but but
this is this is where they're at they're
at a spot where they have to do this
stupid thing that that they're doing
they're projecting the thing that
they're saying Democrats are doing why
isn't my [__] Mouse working I want
them oh
there it goes okay maybe maybe maybe my
mouse is getting uh crazy here oh there
it is okay let's keep listening
that includes discrimination against
Asian Americans the Marxism being did
you catch that how they cut it yeah that
includes discrimination against Asian
American there was more yeah there's
more he went on a tangent there right I
it's I just want to know because yeah
because I I almost bet the cut part is
like we you know we love Asians even
though the created the channel there is
right I mean he probably went on this
[__] racist diet tribe after he said
that so like oh God we gotta cut that
[__] yeah I know it honestly is one of
those things where he's like where would
it have gone if you didn't cut it
because obviously where they cut it
they're like okay this is like a break
where we're like okay he takes a breath
and we can get away with cutting it
right but the inclusion of Asian
Americans like only Asian Americans just
and they cut it yeah because he went on
a diatribe and didn't include like I
don't know other [__] marginalized
communities at all probably and he
probably actually oh some some Asians
are good most are bad they're murderers
unless you know unless
uh which is very interesting because he
goes over he goes after Elaine chow and
he calls her uh chow chow which again
racist right uh so if there's any racism
it's coming out of trump
but
I wonder if he included or they kept it
because he was like oh man I'm pulling
really poorly with the Asian community
so if I throw the Asia they gotta have
that in here as like victims right right
and he goes in the script to be clear in
the script because it really feels like
to me they cut it abruptly because he
went on some [__] racist tangent yeah
they're like oh I would love to see the
outtakes the bloopers my god listen they
could prob they could probably charge
hundreds of that this is a good grift
hey Liz if you're listening get tell the
Cheeto dust kiwin on her this might be a
good grip only fans right people would
pay a ton of money for the [__]
outtakes because I'm sure it's exactly
like when he couldn't say yesterday
yesterday's pretty it's pretty hard for
me to say I can't say yesterday
yesterday I don't want to say it don't
want to say it yesterday is yesterday's
news and I don't want to say yesterday
because I can't say yesterday yesterday
yeah
okay so let's continue here because it
gets much worse he preached in our
schools is also totally hostile to
judeo-christian teachings and in many
ways it's resembling an established new
religion can't let that happen
oh my God so what I I so I I I'm not
sure exactly what he's projecting here
but it feels like to me that he's
projecting Q Anon right yeah like
because because this Q Anon delusion
about education and about uh gender and
wokeness and CRT and all this [__] that
they do to set to actually sexualize
education because it's them sexualizing
it right because they see they see
someone dressed up in a certain costume
reading to children like oh my God that
makes me get all feeling weird inside
with my sexual loins so it must be said
like what is the one what is that
sensation what is that feeling why am I
why am I getting why am I getting a
boner right while I'm walking
and it's them it's them that's doing it
right but so I think what he's saying
though here is this is hey uh Christians
we want Christian schools and we want
everyone to be Christians in schools and
if you you're not a Christian then
you're not going to be in school I think
that's what he's saying here I mean and
I don't think I would assume around the
bush right like
pledge allegiance say a prayer start
your class with the first one that is
why Trump is great or it's the history
of Donald Trump an ongoing Evolution it
sounds familiar this sounds from it so
you're saying they would have like a
picture of him with the next to the flag
and then maybe instead of holding their
hand over their heart maybe they would
make the kids salute him in some way oh
maybe they would like stick their hand
out and yeah yeah like I don't know it's
in some direction right forward area
to take but not exactly how Josh Hawley
would do it because he really kind of
got a the the hand gesture that I'm
thinking of wrong right but something
similar to that probably pretty close
pretty close seems like we have that
somewhere in history that we can look
back and see what happened but let's
let's continue for this reason my
Administration will aggressively pursue
potential violation nations of the
establishment laws and the free exercise
clause of the Constitution he has no
idea what those are no questions he does
not know what those are and the best
part of it is he's acting like he's
president already right he's like my
administrate what administration
when I'm giving power
when I get when you're joking
when Joe Biden is out of the others
[Music]
I will make sure that your children will
only be educated in a white Christian
nationalist school and that no one else
would be welcome I mean that's literally
what he's saying okay let's let's
continue it's very simple additionally
on day one we will begin to find and
remove the radical zealots and marxists
who have infiltrated the Federal
Department of Education okay so if you
aren't aware
um in 1930s and 1940s Germany
um they kind of said the exact same
thing and I don't know if you know this
but it led to six million Jewish people
being murdered it was a holocaust it was
a genocide of a race of people in
Germany six million I don't know if
you're aware of that or not maybe just
maybe you should go back and look at
what what Hitler was saying in his
speeches but it sounded something like
this sounded like this uh around it he's
gonna round up people who he deems who
are marxists Jesus [__] Christ like
you don't the quiet part out loud is not
even a phrase that we need I mean do you
think he'd put them on buses or trains
like where is he gonna take them right
right because remember because remember
if anyone else remembers
Republicans talked about education camps
remember this was this was the topic of
discussion last year in 2021 and maybe
possibly 2020 but definitely 2021. a lot
of people were talking about sending
people to education camps right Ron
DeSantis uh even talked about uh this
re-education uh course or wow however I
mean raised it for teachers right no I I
think you're giving a lot of credit if
you believe that if these [__] [__]
bags took power and do what they want to
do that they would actually put people
in concentration camps look they learned
something from Nazi Germany okay they
learned their lesson they would not do
concentration camps they would they
would March these people straight to a
gas chamber okay well I mean exactly I
also think that if you were to bring up
concentration camps they might be like
why would people need to go to Camp to
concentrate right that seems a little
ridiculous right just make the orange
juice you ain't got to have the orange
juice concentrate when you buy it off
the shelf okay let's let's continue
and that also includes others and You
Know Who You Are Holy [__] okay okay I I
need to stop there because I I stopped
it before I should have stopped it
You Know Who You Are
uh I I really don't know who those feet
do you know who those people are that
he's gonna that he's gonna [__] round
up
I don't know probably people that don't
look like well you have to find anyone
who who doesn't look white probably oh
my God if other people you know you are
wink hey manga supporters we're talking
about blacks Jews people of color
Mexicans anyone you don't like
Muslims non-christians wink all those
other people you know who you are this
[__] dog whistle [__] this
piece of garbage what a piece of vile
trashy is let's I'm telling you the
reason why we're listening to this is
because you have to know this [__]
because when you when you are out there
talking to someone and they think Trump
is good for education and you have not
seen this and you don't know what the
[__] he's saying because they they have
not seen this this on true social
these people who are out there going
Trump's the greatest president of all
time he's going to fix education they
said on Newsmax that Trump's going to
fix education and that and then an
elementary school in Illinois got five
billion can you believe that they they
they're not gonna watch this to know
what he's saying you have to tell them
and the only way you can tell them is to
watch it yourself let's
allow anybody to hurt our children Joe
Biden is good he's not gonna allowing
anybody I there's a list out there of
[__] Republicans
I mean that's a long list let's just go
to the chairman of the Judiciary
Committee let's go there first so is he
saying he's going to round up Jim Jordan
because I mean by this standard by this
standard of projection Jim Jordan's one
of the first that he's gonna round up oh
yeah because Jim Jordan was an education
Jim Jordan worked in a university he
ignored he ignored when his students
were being molested completely ignored
the sex crimes that that were being done
to his students have you seen the have
you seen the videos of trump where he
kisses he grabs and kisses kids on stage
and the kids are like what the [__] why
wouldn't you have you seen the one where
he walks into a classroom and the kids
just like freaked the [__] out and
they're like running away oh yeah oh my
God okay there's another there's another
one where there was a it was four
Turning Point USA I think yeah and it
was a college uh a college student this
woman she was introducing Trump right
she's like oh and you know now the
president United States Donald Trump
and he came up and was like oh thank you
and then like went in for a kiss and she
was like leaning away like things and it
was like this back and forth will they
won't they and Trump was like well can I
[__] you you know it was scary can I
grab you by the you know what wait yeah
it was very [__] weird okay let's
we're running that I really should have
left two hours just to do this video I'm
sorry I apologize let's keep going
giving these lunatics unchecked power I
will have them meaning he wants he wants
unchecked powered see I will tell
Congress that any Appropriations bill I
signed must reaffirm the president's
ability to remove defiant employees from
the job so he literally is saying I want
you to make me dictator of all schools
in the entire country but if you don't
give properties to the white kids [__]
your democracy where you [__] your
democracy where you elect where you
elect school board members I want all
the power he's literally telling you he
wants to be Hitler folks I don't know
know how more to [__] like put it out
there and I don't know how you can do
more to say the exact thing he's saying
he is telling you that he wants Congress
a republican Congress to make sure that
he has the authority over all schools
everywhere negating the Department of
Education negating your local democracy
your local ballot in your local [__]
government of the school board and your
school district Donald Trump is going to
be Hitler in this instance folks I don't
know how you can't [__] see this [__]
but it's right there in front of your
face of what he's saying and what they
want to do and the reason why Marjorie
Taylor green is coordinating with him
with this stupid [__] lie that some
school in Blue State Pete cared
communist Illinois is is getting five
billion dollars
you want to know why he's now pushing
this uh this education bit well now I I
mean there's a lot of different reasons
but give me yours well the main reason
uh what I believe and I think it's the
it's probably a strong one is you've got
Rhonda okay right yeah first off yeah
right there's a whole like Republican
like oh this you know education is bad
right because they don't like he he
loves the poorly educated Ron DeSantis
is another example like that's a primary
motivation you've got some guy who
potentially is going to run against you
and potentially is doing better than you
in the initial polls right and you have
to compensate your ego by saying well
look at this made up chart that somebody
just you know created and [__]
you know Google spreadsheet or whatever
and we're going to throw up on true
social we're going to show you how I've
got 50 of the vote and Rhonda Sanchez
has 30 of the vote right
the so now Trump who never really spoke
about education before that right
education was never even on his like
policy or one of the columns in his his
agenda
but now now that he sees Ron DeSantis
and potentially getting a popular
reception from Republicans is if we ban
these books and we take out this law we
don't talk about CRT we do this and we
don't do that he understands rightfully
so uh that his base gets riled up over
that [__] right and they love that [__]
and he needs that [__] to make money off
of uh to then support his campaign so
now he's like look he went this far I'm
gonna go even further and say that I
will now be dictator and I decide the
curriculum and I decide the books and I
decide who's the teachers and I decide
who the teachers are and I make sure
that the only people who are going to
get support in the classroom from
resources teaching and other things are
going to be
well you know I said in the first 30
minutes and I think you're dead on I
said a little differently I said Trump
is trying to out Hitler DeSantis but
let's um he's trying to out Hitler to
Santa's that's just let's keep going
it's all about our children I will veto
the senator I want full control over
whatever you want to do but that it's
not about me it's not about me and my
power it's about your children yeah okay
[__] your effort to weaponize Civics
education we will keep men out of
women's sports and we will with the
whole [__] credentialing body
anti-trans that will be the goal
anti-lgbtq is what yeah to certify
teachers who Embrace patriotic values
support our way of life and understand
that their job is not to indoctrinate
children but very simply to educate them
be a supporter of me yeah be a supporter
of me and if they're not a loyal
supporter me I get rid of them that is
how it works in government that how
democracy works that's how a republic no
it's not right I mean also just the fact
that
funding also the fact of like education
versus uh indoctrination right it's it's
semantics right it's uh oh well I'm not
indoctrinating I'm educating them with
this stuff which it's propaganda so I am
indoctrining them with either subliminal
messaging or like explicit over like
just over the top
um of messaging to say you know
America's great and so am I and you
should get on your knees and you know
bow down with your hands in a certain
direction
you know I've got a lot of nicknames for
this [__] scumbag and there's mango
Mussolini Jesus there's a Cheeto dust
cue in honor and formerly the Cheeto
dust mobster there's Grandpa Poopypants
but I got I got a new one from this
video and I think I'm gonna add it to
the list and I apologize for everyone to
have to go through all these nicknames
at all at once
but the the groomer in Chief is uh the
groomer the groomer Chief is this
video's name is the groomer in Chief
let's keep going
favorable treatment for all states and
school districts that make the following
historic reforms in education here we go
one Trump abolish teachers
so we can remove bad teachers and adopt
Merit pay to reward good teachers which
I want to plan that's the opposite of
what he just said he just said while ago
that he wants to make it to where he can
fire anyone for any time for anything
and he has the power so that's the
opposite you also know how merit-based
teaching is actually bad I mean I'm sure
people can be incentivized to if they
perform well because they actually care
about teaching but merit-based can also
be uh manipulated in that you know I you
know because Merit is also is based on
scores right test scores which is a
horrible way to teach a horrible way to
figure out if someone's being educated
exactly based on test scores but also
based on oh how is your grade performing
right what what uh what level grade are
they reading at right what what level
grade is their math at right you're
always getting an assessed to be like is
your teaching curriculum falling behind
or your students falling behind on the
curriculum are they actually picking it
up are they is it too slow of a
curriculum and they actually need to do
more challenging you know uh um
Collaborative Learning environment type
of exercises
when you go to Merit a lot of the time
and you see this in other Industries too
but when you go to Merit you'll find
that people go oh great well if I get
good grades right if I show good
performance with through testing
then I will get money so I'm going to
teach to test not teach to learn exactly
I I want to point out something here
real quick before we continue this
because I got to get to the Pink Hair
Academy thing so we might have to go a
few minutes but my freeze my pausing uh
skills here are [__] excellent yeah
someone someone draw a big huge yeah
never mind I'm not gonna let's keep
going we want great teachers in our
schools to drastically cut the bloated
number of school administrators
including the costly divisive and
unnecessary diversity equity and
inclusion bureaucracy oh my God can you
imagine inclusion equity and Equity oh
my God what demons those things are what
bad words how in the [__] did these
things become bad words Jesus Christ
well they became bad words when they
made people feel bad right well you
remember the old [__] bracelets that
said wwjd what would Jesus do good Lord
how [__] far they've come right like
God damn you know I know
yeah yeah but but you know what I'm
talking about that the sentiment that
there's some kind of [__] he said
they're J they want
judeo-christian values in the [__]
school and then he's like oh diversity
and equity and and all the all the
Kumbaya stuff that that Jesus Freak did
that guy named Jesus Christ [__] that
remember when our fun our founding
father said that you know men were
created equal and then over over the
time the length of time in which our
country was founded to now we've we've
uh passed different laws and bills that
say Hey this person should get equal
rights right there's different
amendments like the 14th Amendment which
they [__] hate I mean this is all
stupidity and this is all [__]
fascism laid to Bear he's not even
saying the quiet part out loud anymore
he's just saying exactly what he wants
to say this ain't a quiet part or out
loud they're just they're just they just
want Nazi Germany they just want fascism
because they're they're tired of not
being able to tell you what you can do
and what you can't do let's go three
adopt a parental Bill of Rights that
includes complete curriculum transparent
currency and a form of universal school
choice and four implement the direct
election of School principles by the
parents it's all about the parents for
their children okay you already do that
I don't know I don't know if people know
this you already do that what you do
when especially even if you don't have
school children in your in your District
you go and you elect school board
members what I don't know if you know
this or not but you go elect school
board members to run the school district
and to do that and to make sure that
that curriculum stuff happened the other
thing that you do which is kind of crazy
is kind of crazy I know you elect State
officials like um a governor and a
governor appoints appoints most of the
time appoints someone in charge of your
State's Department of Education and
what's crazy what's crazy what's crazy
is you also normally in states most
state constitutions allow for the Board
of Education in the in the state to be
elected officials in Most states not all
but they have state boards of people who
I don't know it's kind of crazy come up
with curriculum these things that he's
saying already happened and parents
already have the ability to have choice
of you just gotta I don't know know how
[__] Civics Works knows how your
democracy Works know that your ballot
and your [__] vote matter and why
they matter this is important [__] but
he's relying on people not knowing that
like yeah parents need to have more we
need to be voting for the people who are
in charge of that [__] it's ridiculous
that a bunch of workers take over to
school and they're just do doing
whatever they want over there and we
have no it's like we can't even go to
their meetings and yell them scream into
microphones and call them names and [__]
it's it's ridiculous that we don't get
to elect people to make these decisions
for us in our community it's a really
[__] dumb [__] it's really stupid
[__] that we have we are so [__] we
are so far down this Q Anon hole that
people don't realize your choices with
your ballot you [__] right
let's let's keep going
more than anyone else parents know what
their children need if anybody not
really but yeah getting the job done the
parents should be able to vote to fire
them and select someone who will I
thought he was going to fire him what
the [__] is he talking about
I thought he was going to be in full
what is the I don't know this is stupid
he's like I've got he's like I've got
crazy good plans crazy good ideas which
already exist right right right they
already exist and the ones that don't
exist they're [__] fascists as hell
right let's keep going the mid form of
local control local control oh my God
never happened that is all that actually
one of the most locally controlled forms
of government that the federal
government funds in this country is
education it's education folks it's one
of the [__] things that the federal
government gives billions of dollars for
every year to the states that is all
under local [__] control you [__]
boneheads don't even know that he he's
just gaslighting the [__] out of you
yeah he's gaslighting the absolute [__]
out of you and he's like give me the
presidency I'll be the dictator but um
I'm also going to do the things that we
already do because I want you to believe
that we're not already doing them in
this air how things work it's really
stupid but keep going because I gotta
get to the pink Care communist moment
however long it takes add anything like
it or let's say for at least the last 50
years as the saying goes Personnel is
policy I gotta go back to the 50 years
thing he wants to turn the clock back 50
years that's what he means by that right
he's like 50 years ago everything was
great when white people were in control
and white men were in control of
everything women were Barefoot in the
kitchen and people of color knew their
place in society and I don't know like
um 50 years ago if you really kind of go
back it was right after the Civil Rights
Movement but he would like make take it
a little further yeah I was gonna say he
probably wants to go a little before
where he's like look you go to a
different bathroom and there's a
different [__] phone said that you
have right well he definitely he
definitely wants to tell people which
bathroom they can and cannot go into and
which water fountain they can drink out
and it's probably not it's probably not
exclusively limited to just those of a
certain gender or sexuality it's
probably those of a certain skin color
like look white people you get this
fancy ass gold plated toilet bathroom
and everyone else there's an outhouse or
a ditch or a bush in the back if you
need it right well and I want to point
out again my [__] Freeze Frame skills
here I don't know how I do this but I
just think he he just it's the reason is
because it's so easy to find is because
he accentuates every single letter that
he says
and so when you freeze it he's like
either doing one of three poses he's
like
the suck move or the the biting move I
don't know it's [__]
United
damn it okay let's let's get to the pink
haired commie moment because it's oh
it's beautiful let's listen I don't
think
and if they have pink haired Communists
teaching our kids we have a major
problem okay there it is folks there it
is and I mean there's more to it go
[__] listen to it yeah but that's
they moved from blue haired lips right
skincare commies well Gabe listen blue
is a alpha male color right is a beta
female color okay right right men cannot
be alphas and wear pink and they
definitely cannot have pink hair and be
Alpha so they don't get to be teachers
because the the the the uh groomer in
Chief says so because his fake
Administration that he has now will make
sure that and I'm I'm actually sure that
there's some q and honors out there that
actually believe that he's already doing
these he's like oh yeah Trump's the
president and he's gonna fire all those
[__] woke teachers he's gonna fire
all them it's gonna be great I am again
and military is gonna it's gonna make
sure of it uh not that I like Nazi
Germany at all or anything all right and
then
oh like yeah these facts I never said
that I never this is crazy I know uh it
took a while to get through that clip
and really honestly um go put that link
somewhere where you can find it because
you're you're gonna you're gonna need it
um to show to someone at some point
because it is a a horrible horrible idea
to put this [__] idea into place
because it is overt fascism my mouse is
not working with a [__]
I don't even know if I can end the show
I think if you just do this wait just
quit the browser no no no I'm good now
okay I got my mouse back okay it finally
connected back um so everybody uh I
appreciate you staying over just a
little bit over time so we can watch
um the the
whole I what I oh I said holy Hitler
Youth Batman the Hitler Youth video
um where he gets all confused about what
um what fascism is and isn't and he
doesn't say the quiet part out loud it's
just the part it's just just the part
yeah it's just the part it's not the
quiet part it's not out loud anymore
it's just the part they're [__] Nazis
they're America First Nazis and again
like you said Gabe he is trying to out
Hitler desantos the Florida governor not
to be confused of George Santos right
right the Florida governor Ron desantos
Anthony devolder right uh sand Aunt
George Anthony devolder Santos sabrovsky
uh dos Santos is another one I've seen
in my research the scam Syrian candidate
they're all Spam churian candidates at
this point everyone make sure to follow
us and subscribe here on YouTube it's
free to subscribe on YouTube it doesn't
cost you a [__] nickel to subscribe
on YouTube it doesn't cost you a goddamn
thing to listen to this show every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for
two full hours speaking of that in the
second hour tomorrow as we do every
Friday it is bonehead of the week so
make sure you follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod you can vote for bone
end of the week there you can also vote
on YouTube so again another reason to
subscribe for free just go to the
community tab you will be able to vote
for bone in a week and we will break it
down tomorrow on the show
in the second hour you can also download
every single episode which you should be
doing every single afternoon as soon as
I get it uploaded on Apple Spotify
Google whichever is your favorite
directory you can also watch this on the
upwire YouTube channel Gabe there's this
new Creator uh YouTube channel it's the
upwire.com just go to upwire.com you can
follow go to YouTube channel there's
going to be a ton of content creators
there's going to be more and more as we
go along so go check out that YouTube
channel as well everyone
oh there you go there you go uh so be
looking for that I'll retweet that from
the uh from the Twitter accounts
um and also if you give me a link I'll
put it on the Facebook page so follow us
on Facebook at the Tony Michaels and
keep sending me those I'll post the
links to the what was that on the
Facebook page at the Tony Michael so
follow us if you have a Facebook account
if you can stand it
um follow us at the Tony Michaels and
also if you're on Twitch
um make sure to log in with your Prime
account and you can get a free
subscription and you'll be ad free you
won't have to watch ads if you use that
free subscription by logging in with
your Prime account over on Twitch uh
everyone thanks for being here today
thanks for staying over time to listen
to Grandpa poopy pants the groomer in
Chief talk about his Hitler Youth plans
here in this country if he becomes the
nominee which he will and if he becomes
a president which he never will because
that's your job and that's our job to
keep it up we're going to keep going
fighting for democracy at the same time
same place tomorrow we'll be fighting
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon